[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن الان في البلده القديمه في العلا
عمرها سبعه قرون تعد نموذج للترابط
الاجتماعي الذي تمتاز به العلا منذ القدم
تكونت من اكثر من 900 مبنى تم تشهيدها من
الطوب الطيني وهي محاطه ايضا بعدد من
القلاع باغراض الحمايه والرقابه لاهالي
العلا وقوافل الحجيج وكانت في السابق
عباره عن 14 بوابه عند مداخل العلا وهي
تعمل وفق اجراءات محدده بالدخول والخروج
لتامين مسار قوافل الحشيش
[موسيقى]
منظمه السياحه العالميه تختار البلده
القديمه في العلا كواحده من افضل القرى
السياحيه في عام 20 22 بما يتوافق مع
معايير الاختيار المعتمده لاختيار القرى
السياحيه كمحرك للتنميه تدعم خلق فرص
جديده للوظائف وتلتزم ايضا بالابتكار
والاستدامه بجميع عناصرها الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه والبيئه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تم تطوير البلده القديمه في العلا لتكون
منطقه جذب سياحي بالعديد من المطاعم
المقاهي والمتاجر الصغيره لابناء العلا في
منتجاتهم المحل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا توجت جهودها
لاعاده وهج البلده القديمه ياتي اهتمام
الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا في البلده
القديمه لما تحمله وتسخر به من ارث تاريخ
وثقافه وفن معماري فريد بعد ان اذن ديثار
اجزاء منها منذ بدايات القرن التاسع عشر
الميلادي حيث كانت منطقه مهجوره في معظم
اطرافها الى ان الجهود الشامله لتنميه
المستدامه اعادتها لتكون وجهه ثقافيه
وسياحيه لاهالي وزوار العلا لصباح العربيه
نادي الخماش العلا
[موسيقى]